[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh series
[Music]
welcome to the VR Betty show presented
by the Caesars Palace sports book while
the highest-paid running back to the NFL
underperformed last week my partner in
crime is running up the scoreboard like
bo Jackson in Tecmo Bowl she is
dominating with her best bets this is
our betting insider Kelly Daniella
Stewart and I'm cabby Richards please
update the people with your current
standing sir the first 10 weeks of the
season my best bets on this show 8 1 & 1
and if you're following us on social AB
BR underscore betting on my Thursday
night winner with the Browns minus 3
I've got more of my week 11 picks coming
right up
[Music]
let's kick things off of the marquee
matchups of the week we have the Texans
plus four and a half at the Ravens total
51 and a half I know the Ravens look
rather juicy they've been playing great
ball and this is their first five-game
winning streak in six years but I got a
fade the Ravens here why cuz they don't
cover games at home they've covered only
one other last seven home games I like
the Texans and just a few too many
points Monday night in Mexico City we
have the Chiefs - four versus the
Chargers total of 52 I might be
considering the Chiefs here if the
Chargers were at home but they're on the
road where they excel nine three and one
against the spread their last 13 away
games I like the Chargers on Monday
night the Sunday afternoon game with the
Patriots - four and a half at the Eagles
total 44 and a half both teams coming
off a bye New England four and one
straight up on the road the season
Philadelphia 3 and 1 straight up and
home this season if you follow me on
Twitter you already know what I played
you haven't followed me on Twitter
you're gonna have to wait to the end of
the show let's quickly recap those
marquee matchups of the week
I like the Texans the Chargers you guys
gonna have to stick around for my best
bet and the Pats Eagles game consider
myself much of an expert in anything
other than stealing baseball sounds like
the Houston Astros Drake lyrics and
movies starring the rock beautiful and
since I'm not a football expert I
invited a friend who is
[Music]
an expert in FIFA an expert in call of
duty in an expert in the wide receiver
position amassing over 11,000 yards in
the NFL okay so let's look at some more
matchups and we come up right the first
one Broncos at the Vikings the Broncos
quarterback Brandon Howell making his
first career road start I see you
wincing John in 2002 he played with
three different quarterbacks right for
LA Kidner Achille Smith what is it like
adjusting to a midseason quarterback gee
you know it despite the quarterback
carousel that I had to deal with my game
itself within what's up the par so it
really didn't matter who was throwing
the ball my job was to always be open
chat it wasn't up to par it was a but it
was in the elite like this I love you
okay do you think parts would be hard to
come by considering the quarterback
change for Denver and this young play
call yes yes most definitely anytime
there's a young quarterback coming in
and throwing him into the fire the play
book itself is shrink significantly all
right Chad you were a prime time player
in your era whether with that now
without question so let's look at the
primetime matchup tonight we have the
Bears and the wrath Rams here are the
current wide receiver props offered by
the other sports book okay yeah okay let
me get your thoughts on these three
products Cooper come over under five and
our perception definitely over why is
the Rams leading receiver so that makes
sense yeah Robb woods over/under 55 and
a half receiving yards I'm gonna go
under you're gonna go or he's not
reading about 63 yards again yeah but
okay that's right and then we'll we'll
act Rob excuse me Will Allen Robinson
excuse me
score a touchdown yes plus 190 no minus
230 you say what most definitely yes
even though its first name that Jackie I
got it God he's got three so far this
season I'm sure you'd like to add to
those touchdown numbers which one of
these three receivers will shine the
brightest under the Coliseum lights
I like Cooper cup to shine the brightest
I like the Bears defensive secondary
okay and Robert Woods plays on the
outside which is why I have them on the
under under 55 okay I like the analysis
okay let's go to the next matchup Saints
at the Tampa Bay Bucs a divisional game
you're excited Tampa Bay starts multiple
rookies in the secondary and own the
worst ranked passing defense in the NFL
how would rule breeze and receiver
Michael Thomas attack those young
defender Drew Brees Michael Thomas had
been phenomenal regardless of who
they're playing Michael Thomas leads the
league in receptions and yards therefore
regardless to who they're playing in the
secondary being as bad as the Bucs is
they're gonna be phenomenal regardless
in your experience how did you have it
play against weak secondaries affect
your pregame routine of eating
McDonald's which is a real storm listen
McDonald's is eating whether I was
playing football whether I was golfing
but I've playing people no matter what
it was I was doing McDonald's is always
gonna sound in the morning okay okay
enough with the McDonald House every I
make that as a part of your pregame
routine
yeah no winners look at my card for week
11 which coincidentally includes all the
games Chad's just touched on we're gonna
start off with the Broncos plus ten at
the Vikings total 40 talk about this guy
a lot and why because he has made me so
much money we'll get to that in a minute
but Chad mentioned how this Broncos
offense might sputter in it with an
inexperienced quarterback making his
first road start and I agree the Broncos
15 and 3 to the hunter in their last 18
games so got that one circled coach
Zimmer is my man over here 77% against
the spread at home since 2014 he has
just printing us money not to mention he
keeps his teams under control they have
a buy on deck some teams get a little
distracted
not his 11 oh and one against a spread
before a buy I like the Vikings - 10
the Bears plus 6 at the Rams total of 39
and a half
Chad mentioned he like Alan Robinson to
score the first starts to score a
touchdown an A+ 190 high agree they're
not so sure I agree on the Cooper Cup
over receptions oh why this old line is
decimated Gurley is not the same and
what does that equate to Jared Goff has
no
time what happened last time Jared Goff
played the scene that's right four
interceptions last year Chicago ranks
fourth defensively 7.2 yards per game
allowed
I like the Bears plus six that line
movement tells us a lot and that means
the Bears gonna keep this one close
Chad talked about divisional games
Saints minus five and half of the Bucks
total of 50 I know he thinks Michael
Thomas is gonna dominate but I'm playing
against the Saints here and why because
like he said divisional games always end
up tough New Orleans 31 24 and week five
at home versus Tampa Bay they're
terrible against them though five and
four straight up and against the spread
their last nine meetings the Bucs come
to play today don't forget to sprinkle a
little bit on that money line that is my
card come week 11 cavi that's my
favorite it's bringing okay those you
guys making bets this weekend I salute
you Kelly's answer another like dumb
question so far in the season so let's
get to some of your great questions here
now are the lines of the public with our
bet at but our best asks excuse me do
you take line movement into a cat one
placing your bets absolutely there's
lots of line moving each and every week
in the NFL I always tell you guys to bet
early and often especially to get the
best of the number the example this week
is the Jets open as a one point favorite
here at Caesars it's now Washington -
two and a half
you got a Washington +1 ticket in your
pocket you're already ahead of the game
chase Osborne says recently a local
sports book started offering three team
ten-point teasers I know for the most
part you should avoid parlays and
teasers but ten points is a lot for your
thoughts yeah ten points is a lot it
looks rather juicy and what I love to
know what kind of juice they're charging
you for that bet I only bet two teams
six points users are a dollar twenty
here at Caesar's Palace that is the only
teasers I recommend also make sure
you're teasing through those key numbers
of three and seven in a good example of
a teaser today would be the Jags and the
Jets getting them both up to eight and a
half speaking of teasers you teased it
earlier in the show Patriots
the game of the week this is a Super
Bowl match a rematch of this every
mattress of rule 52 tell me give the
people your best bet
[Music]
so you give seven straight Vesta winners
ended last week when we pushed with the
Browns - three
but we're still riding high eight 1 and
1 on the season we're looking to start
another streak today with the Eagles
plus 4 and a half I've told you guys
this before I have personal rules about
betting against Brady and Belichick so I
know when the key times are to do so we
faded the Pats twice the season that's
right to get the bills which the bills
covered and the Ravens who won outright
Philadelphia getting no respect here 14
and one straight up five and OH against
the spread as an underdog coming off a
bye in divisional games
I know Philadelphia is banged up I know
it's scary to bet against Brady and
Belichick but you gotta do it
Eagles plus four and a half and uh just
for fun we're just gonna sprinkle a
little bit more on that money line let's
recap all of my picks for week 11 these
are listening in order of confidence on
how many units I'd recommend you got on
each I've got a four unit play on the
Eagles three units on the Bears and
Texans remember a unit is your standard
vet amount should be about one percent
of your bankroll I've also got two
percent place aka two units on the
Vikings Bucs Redskins and the Chargers
as we wrap up our week 11 preview this
meme danced its way across the inner
Internet throughout the week featuring
dak Prescott Chad you were on Dancing
with the Stars with sheeted yes you were
cheated I would cheated how so there's
no reason that should have been going to
get Nicole Scherzinger who dances for a
living fair but that's just the
competition and you're supposed to step
up I did step up the way that dak
Prescott R stepped up in this freaking
can you give us your best shot this
camera zoom in on the hips yeah yeah yep
Wow I used to be a Chippendale back in
2005 nothing under mourning might have a
show I have a special guest show tonight
ladies please come out and support
thank you for steering the BR betting
she'll presented by the Caesars Palace
sports book whether you guys like to
fade or follow me you can find all my
pics on social add VR underscore betting
thank you for joining us mr. Chad
Johnson and good luck on all your bets
let's have a profitable Sunday please
don't forget ladies night 9:30
Chippendale Boutros up again
[Music]